[Aplausos]
algunas personas son personas puentes
algunas vienen así de fábrica y otras
como yo nos vamos haciendo en el camino
un poco a cuento de la propia
experiencia y de la historia de vida
alguna vez te cruzaste con una persona
puente
una persona puente es de esas personas
que siembran concordia que ayudan a
otros a encontrar puntos de encuentro
que tienen la disposición de escuchar
desde el corazón lo que el otro tiene
para decir desde lo que siente desde lo
que necesita cuando dice lo que dice en
los relatos que escuchamos
una persona puente es una persona que se
banca
todas las emociones que fluyen cuando el
conflicto está ahí
qué persona puente te acordás que
encontraste en tu vida
una abuela una maestra
algún familiar que andaba mediando entre
otros cuando había alguna discordancia
algún amigo
te acordás que sentías cuando esa
persona te escuchaba
[Música]
te acordás cómo impactaba en sus gestos
y sus palabras
en tu vida
las personas puentes tenemos la no
siempre fácil tarea de ayudar a otros
que inicialmente aparecen en los
extremos del puente simbólicamente a
empezar a escucharse a comunicarse lo
mejor que le salga a poder decir lo que
sienten a poder expresar lo más claro
que puedan lo que necesitan y para qué
lo necesitan y atreverse a hacer el
camino a través de la comunicación de
crear escenarios distintos escenarios
posibles
a veces pactando lo que se puede en ese
momento y otras veces
cruzando juntos el puente
el conflicto no se es inevitable por el
solo hecho de ser humanos y de ser con
otros
lo que venimos aprendiendo es que
depende que hagamos con el conflicto
como lo transitamos y cómo y qué
conductas tengamos frente al conflicto
podemos tener ventanas de oportunidades
o podemos aumentar la frustración la
incertidumbre y la violencia
y en esto de ser personas puentes nos
interesa mucho que la gente recupere la
relación por cuando estamos frente a una
situación de conflicto lo que afectamos
son las relaciones y en las relaciones
ponemos en juego la convivencia eso que
hacemos todos los días todo el tiempo a
veces sin tanta conciencia
entonces el trabajo de una persona
puente es fomentar la relación ayudar a
reparar
en el mejor escenario a cruzar el puente
dice humberto maturana un reconocido
epistemólogo y biólogo chileno que somos
las conversaciones que hacemos y cuando
tenemos una situación de conflicto en
una relación en esas relaciones que
queremos cuidar porque el otro nos
importa alguien de la familia un amigo
un compañero de trabajo mi vecino en
esas relaciones que quiero cuidar
la mejor partida es cambiar las
conversaciones porque si yo cambio las
conversaciones tengo la oportunidad de
cruzar el puente
yo hace 21 años descubrí que tenía
vocación de constructora de puentes y me
dedico a la abogacía preventiva mi
oficio es la mediación y la facilitación
de consensos
intento humildemente poner lo mejor de
mí para ayudar a la gente a hacer
procesos de diálogo
y construir puentes es muy interesante
muy desafiante a veces ocurre la magia y
un constructor de puente no tiene ningún
sentido
si no invita finalmente a que la gente
descubra el potencial y su mejor versión
y se atreva a pensarse una persona
ubuntu y ustedes me dirán que es una
persona ubuntu bueno en la lengua su luz
una lengua sudafricana ubuntu es un
dialecto
y una palabra que significa el poder de
lo colectivo que significa yo soy
persona porque soy persona con el otro
yo soy a partir de los demás permítanme
contarles una historia
dicen que había un antropólogo que
estaba estudiando el comportamiento de
una tribu e invitó a unos chicos a hacer
un juego puso debajo de un árbol una
canasta llena de frutas y los desafió
a que al que llegará primero se llevará
las frutas le iba a dar un premio
cuando dio la orden para que iniciaran
el juego los chicos se levantaron se
tomaron de las manos y juntos fueron a
buscar la canasta de frutas volvieron se
sentaron y disfrutaron el premio esta
persona se quedó un poco confundida y
pregunto por qué hicieron esto si tenían
la chance
de uno solo ganar todo el premio y los
chicos a coro dijeron ubuntu como uno
podría estar feliz si los otros están
tristes
interesante
esta filosofía ubuntu que muchas
personas en el mundo la viven la
encarnan muchas personas que están
comprometidas con la construcción de paz
voy a nombrar sólo dos que me parecen
muy interesantes por el trabajo que
están haciendo en sus países
desmond tutu que es un pacifista
sudafricano
y leyman wing que es una activista
pacifista liberiana son personas
juventud y estas personas muestran un
modelo de convivencia social posible
pero es ingenuo no es romántico es
posible posible porque ellos creen en el
poder del diálogo en el poder de la
transformación del diálogo y en la
posibilidad que la persona se comunique
con la otra a partir de lo de lo que
mejor tiene en su humanidad
pero esto no es tan fácil si no no
estaríamos en los salvajes
todos nosotros tenemos experimentados
el conflicto el conflicto como algo
inevitable que nos atraviesa a todos los
días y todo lo que nos pasa con el
conflicto todo lo que nos mueve
esto es así porque somos personas y
porque estamos en relación con otros
pero decía que de lo que hagamos con el
conflicto nosotros podemos tener una
actitud de víctimas frente al conflicto
o de protagonista frente al conflicto y
podemos decidir cómo gestionar el
conflicto y depende con qué herramienta
se elija gestionar el conflicto puedo
aprender del conflicto o el conflicto me
puede llevar puesto
fíjense conflictos y violencia son dos
situaciones que están ahí
el conflicto es inevitable pero la
violencia puede prevenirse
y depende de vos y depende de mí porque
conflicto inadecuadamente gestionado
genera necesariamente violencia y eso lo
hacemos en las relaciones todos los días
lo hacés vos y también lo hago yo así
que te pregunto qué conciencia tenés
ahora tenemos ahora de la parte que te
toca en la construcción de convivencia
los invito a imaginarse dos situaciones
la primera dos papas jóvenes deciden
separarse
y reparten dos niñas cada uno se queda a
cargo de la crianza de una de las niñas
por mucho tiempo una de las niñas tiene
poco contacto con su hermana y con su
otro progenitor sus abuelos sus tíos sus
primos y hay mucha tristeza en ese grupo
familiar hay tristeza hay rabia y
violencia hay celos
hay denuncias policiales hay medidas
judiciales
pueden ver esta imagen puedan imaginarse
que sienten estas personas o que
pudieron sentir estas personas que
eventualmente pudieron decir
otra situación
dos instituciones educativas comparten
el mismo predio empiezan a tener
dificultades por el uso del edificio y
sobre todo por el uso de los patios qué
es
el bastión común empiezan a dialogar
cada vez menos dialogar
de una manera que no se pueden poner de
acuerdo la gente empieza a tomar partido
se arman bandos los adultos de la
escuela deciden tomar la escuela y un
grupo de padres lo apoyan el sindicato
sale a denunciar la situación y sienta
su postura los medios de comunicación
locales le cuentan a la ciudadanía lo
que está pasando
las autoridades locales y provinciales
empiezan a intervenir los chicos sin
clases
escala el conflicto y aparece la
violencia directa pueden ver esta foto
y estas son dos situaciones que me han
tocado acompañar
y que todos los días están ahí aparecen
todos los días todo el tiempo una es una
a una le llamamos conflictos
interpersonales familiares a las otras
que llamamos conflictos públicos
complejos las dos atraviesan todo el
tiempo la convivencia
y afectan gravemente nuestra calidad de
vínculos y nuestra calidad de vida
la buena noticia es que nosotros tenemos
algo que podemos hacer con esto mira
tenemos dos cosas que podemos hacer la
primera es darnos cuenta que la
violencia la podemos generar nosotros si
gestionamos inadecuadamente nuestros
conflictos y que la violencia es algo
que aprendimos culturalmente y podemos
desaprender así como también podemos
aprender a comunicarnos ya relacionarnos
en forma no violenta
qué le parece esto
y la otra noticia es que siempre podemos
elegir siempre tenemos el poder de
elegir en cualquier situación en
cualquier circunstancia aún cuando no
estemos eligiendo y eres te elegir
podemos elegir ser pensarnos como
personas ubuntu personas que piensan en
el otro como un interdependiente que me
ayuda a satisfacer mis necesidades y
también podemos elegir por vocación o
porque tengo las condiciones ofrecerle
para hacer puentes para otras personas
seguramente algunos de ustedes en estos
días ha protagonizado alguna situación
de diferencia siendo ustedes levanten la
mano por favor ha tenido alguna pelea
con un familiar con un hermano haber
sean sinceros con algún amigo un
compañero de trabajo
bien estuvieron bastante modestos
esto nos pasa a todos todo el tiempo si
no lo tenemos reflexionado pero todo el
tiempo nos está pasando
entonces nosotros podemos prevenir la
violencia toda vez que hagamos
conciencia de qué parte de
responsabilidad tenemos en la situación
de conflicto y cómo queremos pararnos
frente al conflicto y cómo queremos
gestionarlos
acepta ti como sos
banca la diferencia del otro empodera te
acepte cargo de lo que sentís
de lo que decís de lo que pensás de lo
que haces en contraste con otros
participa de los espacios donde estás
participando dale valor a la palabra
escucha te escucha escucha para
comprender
comprende para que te comprendan
presta atención a las conversaciones que
haces
porque las conversaciones tienen poder
tienen poder de construir y tienen poder
de destruir
la convivencia y la violencia son dos
procesos interdependientes como dos
caras de una moneda
y no es una idea romántica ni una ni una
utopía esta filosofía ubuntu la
convivencia consiste en ponerle ficha a
la confianza en las relaciones dialogar
hasta entenderse
es un trabajo no dialogar hasta entender
se es más fácil la ley del ojo por ojo
diente por diente pero dialogar hasta
entenderse es bancar me a mí mismo y
bancar al otro como auténtico otro
miren que tenemos pasado por el cuerpo y
bien aprendido porque se nos pega se nos
pega y se nos naturaleza esto de que se
nos salta lo salvaje
en ese no salta el logo del hombre en el
otro y cuando nos pasa esto sacamos lo
peor de nosotros y aparece el sálvese
quien pueda y en el sálvese quien pueda
perdemos todos
así que la convivencia es una tarea es
un trabajo que exige de nosotros de voz
y de mi estado de presencia estado de
atención en las relaciones que me
importan y que quiero cuidar de la
relación con mi amigo con mi pareja con
mi hijo con mi vecino con mi compañero
de trabajo aquellas relaciones que
quiero cuidar son las relaciones
piden de mi presencia total en las
conversaciones
relaciones de diálogo y relaciones de
confianza esta tarde te invito a renovar
la esperanza te invito a que te hagas
cargo y ejerza el derecho a vivir en paz
te invito a recuperar tus sueños
individuales y tus sueños colectivos
te invito a pensar la convivencia como
una responsable
ubuntu
[Aplausos]